امام اعداد هائله من المرضى يفوقون قدرته
الاستيعابيه بعشره اضعاف صمد القطاع الصحي
بمارب لثماني سنوات موجات النزوح
المتواصله الى مارب تحملت اعباءها
مستشفياته ومراكز صحيه قليله بكادر محدود
وبامكانيات تطورت لتواكب المرحله في تقديم
خدمات طبيه وعلاجيه للامراض والاوبئه التي
انتشرت في مجتمع نازحين يوصل في اليوم الى
قرابه الالف حاله في ضغط شديد ازدياد
ملحوظ
ومتزايد بشكل يومي كثير من البرامج الان
خلال العام الجديد 2023
ابلغنا من المنظمات انها قيده التوقف وهي
اللي كانت ساند لتخفيف الكثير من المعنى
في هذا المحافظات كان هذا المبنى لمستشفى
الريفي ارتقى تحت ضغط النازحين الى مستشفى
عام يستقبل اكثر من الف حاله في اليوم
لكنه هو الاخر مهدد بتوقف كثيرا من برامجه
العلاجيه المموله من المنظمات الدوليه
التي اعلنت سحب التمويل بنسبه 65% عن
القطاع الطبي خلال العام الجاري يجب ان
محافظه بالذات اذا كان فيه هناك
خمس اسباب سبب الاول هو ان الكادم الخادم
المحافظه كامل الحرب محيطه بمنام كل
الاتجاهات الاوبئه معنى في الاوبئه بشكل
كثير في كبد المحاضر الشيء الثاني النزوح
والسكن والوضع اللي فيه الناس في الصفيح
في ساكن في خيام وقف تمويل المنظمات
الدوليه بدا فعليا في مركز الامومه
والطفوله منتصف العام 2022
وظل العاملون الصحيون المرتبطون بعقود مع
تلك المنظمات يعملون دون استلام حوافزهم
طبعا هذا المستشفى هو المستشفى المرجعيه
الوحيد للمحافظه في مجال الامومه والطفوله
بالنسبه للحضانات
واذا توقف توقفت المنظمات عن دعم المستشفى
فالمستشفى
يقبل على كارثه المجتمع في الوقت الذي
يحتاج القطاع الطبي بمارب الى زياده الدعم
توقف المنظمات الدوليه برامجها ضغط كبير
يشهده القطاع الصحي في محافظه مارب خلال
ثمان سنوات من الحرب والنزوح وسط تدخلات
شحيحه من المنظمات الدوليه محمود الحميدي
العربيه مارب